[موسيقى]
يعد وسط العاصمه البوسنيه سراييفو مركزا
تاريخيا وثقافيا يعكس جزءا من الحضارات
التي مرت بهذه المنطقه الجبليه الاوروبيه
فسوق بشتريشا الذي يقع على الضفه الشماليه
لنهر ملياكا يعود الى حقبه الامبراطوريه
العثمانيه وازقته تشبه البازارات التركيه
القديمه فهنا تباع الحلويات التقليديه
كالحلقوم والكنافه والبقلاوه وتحتس القهوه
البوسديه في المقاهي الشعبيه وتباع
الهدايا التذكاريه في حواليت تقليديه
صغيره
[موسيقى]
مسجد غازي حورس بيك هو مسجد تاريخي يعود
الى القرن السادس عشر ويعد الاكبر في
البوسنه والهرسك يعكس فن الاماره
العثمانيه في منطقه البلقان تم تاسيسه في
عام
1753 على الطراز المعماري العثماني الانيق
في محيط المسجد نجد ماء سبيل تاريخيا
تزوده مياه عذبه تنحدر من الجبال الثلجيه
المحيطه بسرع ايفو وتعلو ماذنه مسجد غازي
ساعه فريده تعد اخر ساعه شمسيه وحين تدق
الساعه الثانيه عشر فهذا يدل على موعد
غروب الشمس وليس منتصف النهار
[موسيقى]
هي واحده من افضل البلدان في منطقه
البلقان التي تحتفظ ليومنا هذا بتراثها
العثماني المعماري والاثري هذا جميل
للزائر الغربي والشرقي كذلك التاثير
العثماني كان في بلدان عده هنا في دول
البلقان لكن الامبراطوريه العثمانيه لم
تترك هذه المنطقه في اجواء حرب بل قامت
بمعاهدات مع العرش النمساوي بحيث يحافظ
على الاثار والهندسه المعماريه العثمانيه
للبوسنه على وضعها وكذلك الحال مع
الاحتلال المجري والاوروبي لبلدنا
[موسيقى]
الحي النمساوي من سراييفو يعكس حقبه غربيه
بكنائسها وبيوتها التاريخيه وشوارعها التي
تعج بالمقاهي والمتاجر يشعر الزائر لاول
وهله وكانه في مدينه سلافيه النمساويه
بامتياز
[موسيقى]
الى جانب معالمها السياحيه والتاريخيه
تجمع سراييفو بين الشرق
والغربها المعماري ويوجد هنا في الماده
القديمه خط فاصل يجسد بين حقبتين الاولى
الحقبه العثمانيه في القرن السادس عشر
وحقبت الاستعمار النمساوي من عام 1878 الى
عام 1918 اي في القرن التاسع عشر من عاصمه
البوسنه والهرسك
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات